Microsoft is the only Tech Giant that
hasn't created a revolutionary product
within the past 10 to 20 years Apple has
the iPhone Google has Chrome Amazon has
AWS Tesla has electric self-driving cars
and even met up is trying with the
metaverse but what about Microsoft
Microsoft is still really only known for
two products windows and Microsoft
Office and it's been nearly 40 years
since Windows was released and over 30
years since office was released for
those of you commenting that they
created chat jbt they didn't create that
they bought it and this is really the
secret to behind their success over the
past 15 years they've been trying to buy
themselves to the top